[Música]
las comunidades indígenas que estuvieron
en la búsqueda y la fuerzas militares
conjuntamente
encontraron a los niños 40 días después
estaban solos habían sido ellos mismos
lograron un ejemplo de sobrevivencia
total digamos que quedará en la historia
[Música]
la esperanza
de ahí me llamaron a mí yo yo no creí
pero la verdad después yo otra vez me
llamaron que sí estaba seguro cuando ya
Henry Guerrero me llamó tranquila
fatimita ya encontramos su nieto los
cuatro vivos tranquila ya después le
aviso todo bien
[Música]
no pude hablar con ellos pero
simplemente eran ojos lo poco lo poco
que pude interactuar más bien eran ojos
de asombro ojos de gratitud ojos de
esperanza de que vieron una nueva
oportunidad para vivir
[Música]
pues la verdad me parece un milagro la
verdad no sabía que iban a aparecer
vivos y la verdad es algo que no se
logra creer y me alegra bastante que ya
se encuentren con vida y a salvo
[Música]